- So your big break
obviously was on X-Factor
and I came up on Idol.
So, you came up with a
group, which I think is cool.
I think
(crowd cheering)
I was, we do know of them, but no, I just,
I was very lonely, like
off the top, like I was 19,
a little older whenever
I started, but like,
I was very lonely and I think
that must have been cool,
like, that you had,
like, buddies to lean on
and, like, do y'all still have that?
Do you have that, like, we have a group,
- Yeah.
- Well we have a group text
we can't tell anyone about.
(Kelly laughs)
But we have a group text,
like, with The Voice coaches,
but do y'all still, do you have that,
do you have that kind of camaraderie?
I just, I would love that.
- Yeah, no, we were so,
especially on the show, we were so lucky.
Like, 'cause you would
see all the other artists
melting all the time over everything.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We were just 16, 17,
18, 19 whatever we were.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(crowd cheers)
But that's, like, kinda awesome that you,
had people to lean on.
- [Niall] It was great. Yeah.
- [Kelly] I just, I would've loved that.
- [Niall] It was so fun, definitely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Niall] I'd do it again.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- That's why I'm doing The Voice.
(Niall laughs)
- I would do it again, too.
I love doing The Voice for that reason.
- [Niall] Yeah.
- It is actually cool.
Full circle moment that you
get to say I've been in your,
I don't like that that's
your pitch though.
'Cause that's my pitch.
- Yeah. She uses it like,
"I came from a show like this and, uh,
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd cheers)
and then I was, like, "Wait
'til you see what I've got."
(Kelly laughs)
(Niall laughs)
- I was like, damn it.
- Me too!
But yeah, no, of course,
we speak constantly so it's a,
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Good little thing to have.
- Yeah, I was like, I
always looked at groups
like that and I'm, like,
ah, that would've been cool.
- [Niall] Yeah.
- To just have someone to talk-
- But you won on your own.
- It's okay.
No, this is the greatest thing.
- This is so funny by the way.
- Wait, so we're doing
a skit for The Voice,
I thought One Direction won.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
I mean, 'cause you did, in life.
(audience cheers)
You go, "Actually we came in
third," and I was like, "What?"
(audience laughs)
I was like, 'cause I
didn't watch, I just, like,
knew that's where you came from.
- But like, congratulations.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- [Kelly] You killed it, by the way.